You did awesome.
>> Is that your American accent?
>> Oh, I don't know.
All right, anyway, in this course,
you learned that your options for
images go well beyond
a simple image tag.
In fact, you can use the browser's
properties to not only change the source
of the image to ease, you know,
bandwidth requirements, but
you can also change the content of
the image using the picture element.
>> And you learn that images
aren't always necessary.
There are markup alternatives
like icon fonts and
CSS styles that give you low
bandwidth options for images.
>> But most importantly,
you learned that images
are an integral part of your
development workflow for modern sites.
Images constitute an enormous percentage
of page load, and screen sizes and
form factors vary so widely.
Responsive design requires preparing
your images for any device.
>> Now, you can develop images for
all of these devices.
>> Beauty.
>> [LAUGH] Heck, yeah.
>> What?
>> I don't know.
>> [LAUGH] See you.
>> Bye.